I am obsessed with tinder okay hi guys
I'm Greg hi I'm Avery why not say I'm
tinder for the channel simple pickup
you don't need tinder you you can easily
walk anywhere and I think you'll be fine
did you find the guy interesting but
it's so fun to judge people I love to
get glass of wine and just judge judge
judge judge
do you ever swipe right very rare it's
rare what will make you swipe right you
can't have your shirt off in the picture
that means you're induced we have like
me my friends have a list of rules you
have a guitar you get yes automatically
really and mostly I just look at careers
actually it most of time I don't even
look people's face I look at the career
and if they're like something boring
like I don't want to offend anyone what
am I going to offend anyone
no oh well if it says like accountant
bye
whoa accountants are like the number one
fan base of the channel okay I would do
them as accountants are really into
really video reactions Wow yeah I need
some weird and craziness in my life if
you're like a photographer a YouTube
person if you're yours and you're east
saying in a priest a priest is willing
to sleep around a priest dude you wanna
sleep then yes yeah that's it yes while
it is wrong in his wife mm-hmm there
should be some priests on tinder um I
haven't found one yet but market you
know I once had a tender a long time ago
I would not know how to start
conversations oh no she didn't get
people who didn't respond to you they
were but then they would stop what did
you say
I don't remember just like hey no you're
very hot wrong I want to do you to each
other this would be nice oh oh
that they stopped you know if they
didn't reply they'll just keep sending
as many text messages as they could
oh no just many oh that was like you
know if I just keep bombarding them
though eventually they'll reply I don't
want to go on a date with me know when
people do that I think they've met
shoes whatever I think most of the world
will disagree with oh no you gotta you
got a really piqued my interest
you gotta say like something super weird
like like the Jews will save us yeah
like that like that yeah I need to know
you're gonna spice up my life so you
better sum that all up but nothing
sexual nothing sexual no you can say
that from person what if they were like
I want you to use a strap-on on me oh
that was different right that means that
they like boys doesn't mean the lake
boys just like a little bit of anal
pleasure they like boys no it doesn't
Gregg there's something you're not
telling us no that's something I'm not
showing you oh no all right simple
pickup I love this channel by the way
best advice on how to pick up women
apparently that I quickly forget the
best way to meet women is actually go
out and meet women yeah but what if you
want to pick up girls while you're
taking a [ __ ] if you have a smartphone
and a thumb then tinder is your solution
this is how it works what I bang yes no
yes definitely not like anything else
there is a test and science to tender
success yes by now you've got a few
matches now what talk to her before I
tell you how to talk to her I had to
show you how not to talk to her I asked
her friend Kelly to set up a new tinder
account and screenshot the messages she
got why do we do this because we wanted
you to see real messages from real
people so you know exactly what to avoid
in less than 24 hours of 10 drinks she
got over 600 messages from men let that
really sink in every cute girl you're
talking to is getting bombarded with
messages we broke down the messages she
got into three categories the generic
compliments the dull openers and the not
so bad
18 percent of messages were just a
generic compliment mister things like
wow I must say you're beautiful you're
absolutely gorgeous
hope you don't take offense to me
thinking you're adorable oh here's a
good one you look very hot in your pics
while this might work in
like oh my everyone's doing it
52% of messages were just boring as [ __ ]
things like how you doing hi hey how are
you hello hey smiley face 8% we're so
bad that I just have to show you some of
them I don't know why a lot of guys do
this but they pretend like they've never
been on tinder before and they're so
naive they say things like hi Wow
so this tender thing he actually works
just joined tinder version here I never
do this
tinder thing how's it going oh this
one's good I truly don't mean to sound
rude or in any way disrespectful by
saying this but I honestly think you're
really pretty you have extremely nice
hair and your smile truly boosts up your
attractiveness again I mean no
disrespect I'm just simply acknowledging
your beauty yeah and then there was a
very small minority of messages that
weren't so bad I'm gonna show you how to
be better than those guys
sweet remember being unique is important
so here's what you should do to avoid
being like most of these guys good this
is the name method simply write her name
with an exclamation mark offer and Shawn
came up with this one super effective
especially if she doesn't have a
detailed bio or a ton of photos to
comment on now this is the best way to
do it if you want some more specific
info you're gonna have to open up her
bio and actually read it
this girl listed the different places
she's lived and also one of our favorite
sports is hockey
watch how I use this information okay
here I use information from her bio to
create an opener about hockey and ash or
a bit of my sense of humor and then I
threw in a dick joke for good measure in
this case I noticed her Halloween
costumes
remember don't filter yourself subtle
hints of sexuality keep it fun and opens
the door for her to flirt right back as
she did here okay and lastly my favorite
roleplay talking to strangers is
supposed to be fun so try this out
role-playing is great because she can
also play along it becomes easy to text
as both of you play out this ridiculous
scenario this is just one example ah of
cute no her like thank yous and she
open up as if you have if you're having
fun she'll have fun
once you've flirted back and forth
transition into getting her number might
be thinking why should I do this we're
already chatting on tinder well once you
get her phone number you actually become
real in her mind you're separating
yourself from every other guy she was
talking to on tinder and when you do
that she's way more likely to commit to
a date once you're in her phone as a
contact you're no longer that guy from
tinder you're a potential date once
you've made it this far and treat her
like a girl you just met off the street
meet up with her take her out go have
fun
you earned it thanks for watching guys
friends over to ask men just created it
dating advice channel go subscribe to
the channel and let them know that
simple pickup sent ya you're supposed to
immediately send a photo of yourself
something that's not on your profile
you're supposed to you know compliment
them heavily bra like luck work like
alright hey crickets you're really high
I would love to hug you in front of
other people hey why did you get my last
message about me hugging you Avery are
you there so many crickets Avery don't
do this to me I really you're the first
one I have ever matched with and this is
made me feel really good
are you real are you a bot what are you
talk to me you say hey have you ever
been guilty of doing the things yeah
totally I'll tell you everything I've
been guilty of yeah hey how are you Bri
why'd you say hey with three wives no do
you like hey three exclamation marks no
that's too desperate there's a desperate
yeah forever look like too excited he
needs to be chill hey how are you huh
like I don't I hate that question
alright alright alright I want to get
this now yeah let's practice come up
okay okay I could show you my bio yeah
what's your bio that's here by then
what'd you tell me well work off your
bio hi I'm a unicorn and then I have all
my social media links because if I'm
gonna be on tinder I might as well just
promote my business singer/songwriter
unicorn so I should try to see what I
couldn't gather from this yeah I would
say hey I just got a quick question are
you a Johnny Cash or Marilyn Manson Ben
C I don't I don't like if you had done
research you'd see this so that's like
go to your year I know you're like yeah
oh oh these guys all go in my youtube
all my messages they're like oh I love
this club I want to see if you're like
really hot in motion - they can see my
videos you can see them real you can see
the interest - oh it's my interest
delete that what do you mean what's
wrong I seen your interest I'm Dairy
Queen they don't like anything anymore
what's ASU hookups Facebook stalking a
minute you do it you should like you
know maybe say something about unicorns
unicorns I obviously like unicorns and
if you really stalked me hard enough
actually just look at the third picture
you notice I have a unicorn on my wrist
so that's probably important to me and
you should probably take notice cuz they
definitely people to know wow this is
hard
online dating is a whole other game I
know so you've never actually gone on a
date with a guy from tinder oh I have
they all it usually ends badly but it's
so much fun
one's a guy he not my toothbrush no what
what are you talking about wait this
[ __ ] you've been saying like this was
the first time you guys were going out
because he got mad he peed on my
toothbrush and he peed all over the
counter and then he left
oh hey sounds about right yeah that
sounds about that sounds about right
it's normal human reaction I've peed on
so many people's toothbrushes that's how
I get my revenge all the time oh go on -
there's lots of girls that'll let you do
that but I don't like is when a girl's
into it though I have to not be into it
well I don't know I spent all day
cleaning it so I don't think I'm into it
you just didn't buy a new toothbrush two
dollars because this idiot decides to
pee on my toothbrush that's not fair do
you still brush your teeth with that
toothbrush that should be on your tinder
profile I feel like that would get you a
lot more you actually use that
toothbrush okay good so you're gonna go
to an actual message that's I don't
think I've ever seen a unicorn before
are they all as cute as you
I love him go on a date with him Avery I
think that's actually kind of cute that
is cute that's cute
can I talk to him oh he's kind of cute
he's really cute you want to talk to her
Wow
oh no you see this is the thing if
they're not wearing a shirt there's
something wrong that's two shirtless
photos the most rub guy yeah maybe likes
a pax no usually guys with a packs of
small dicks and like are really insecure
I'm sorry it's just like every workout
guy I've met is there trying to make up
for something that's why I don't work
out as much we all know what that means
yeah he's got nothing to make up for cuz
he is he's good yeah good I'm ready to
rock and roll at any given moment if I
have enough energy are you a magician
shipping an average oh come on man did
you take that popsicle wrapper in that
joke what's the oldest guy you've hooked
up with Oh like that guy I'm matching
you can't get that personal and
obviously he's just here to hook up I
don't think so I think you're looking
for a serious relationship he hasn't the
oldest guy hooked up with it but sex is
like the most important nutrient to
making a relationship work above
emotional and mental at sex right so it
works I guess that's true if the sex
sucks it does not gonna really work
yeah yeah by everything could be bad
everything could be bad you know but if
the sex is good healthy relationship
writing person aren't you Wow okay
anyone needs help just hit me up I can
totally help you out
I can even respond your messages for you
I'd be willing to log into your tinder
and do it let me know
Avery official you can just tweet me and
I'll do it for you
wow this is special episodes just been
great having you on Avery uh listen if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject cool Avery
official is the channel where Avery is
not only staying good she's singing yep
she's singer
talented singer I may look like one but
she is don't be deceived don't be
deceived by the unicorn yeah on my wrist
why do you like unicorn so much they're
so special and unique and I want to be
special
I just just broke my heart
derpy it's a gerbilcorn you know the
dirt turpis that's a type of toy that
couples use know she wants snapchat
followers two guys by the way before
thanks Anna maybe with three wives
snapchat and a baby three wise follow
her every official Instagram right yeah
yeah yeah a lot of great photos on there
too it's gonna keep you company for a
while
thanks no Rob I